a few nights ago we went to dinner and
there was an old guy there who must have
been I got to be careful even if it is
about 85 or 90 he'd had a stroke he's
very feeble and he walked to his table
that had been LED tube with his very
frail waif and he was offered a chair
like the one year sitting in today no
alarms and he wanted to sit down course
for dinner and he got in front of the
chair and he could see I was sitting
we're seamless next to him and I he
looked at the chair and I lined up dear
am I am I where I'm supposed to be yes I
think so i'd like to try to help you oh
no i don't want to pull you down the
back and forth the the waiters didn't
know what to do nobody knew how to care
for this fellow there was no empathy of
whatsoever this was a good restaurant
what do you do well if they ask us
tonight do you want to do on a
handicapped room I always liked it I
handicapped room no I don't handicapped
room like that's the room without the
minibar in there
this is presumably the room with a
railing in the bathroom right so I can
find my way to the can so I thought of
this chair that we had designed for
striker which we call the Stannis's
chair now this is really for the the
hospital room but I mean you look at the
handles look how far out in front they
are think of my old friend who's trying
to sit down the man with a stroke he
would have put his hands here first
scooted back and then lowered himself
down using his arms but he didn't have
arms on his chair it was they were
designed out all right and they're
flared so that once you're in the chair
you have room to get our arms